well the library now has over a million
physical volumes and we have more
facilities than we did when many people
were here so we have an engineering and
science library a Mellon Institute
library we have hot library we have
Posner Center which has a rare book
collection we have a library in our
campus in Qatar and we have a book
depository where we keep books that
don't circulate very often so we have
many more facilities even than when i
came ten years ago it's really been a
growth time for libraries both in the
facilities that we have in the
collection and also in the electronic
resources that we make available to
students the library at Carnegie
Mellon's a lot smaller than one would
expect for a university of our prestige
that has made us to be a lot more
innovative and so we're a very
entrepreneurial very quickly we began to
digitize the archival collections of
some of our famous faculty and we've
continued to make digitization and
bringing content to the web a very
important part of our service to not
only our campus community but to
everyone around the world well you know
we're very lucky at Carnegie Mellon when
it comes to technology in libraries
because we've been able to partner with
the school of computer science we have a
project that we call the universal
digital library and one of the things
that we've done within it is the million
book project and so we were able in the
million book project to get partnerships
with several universities in India and
several universities in China and we've
now scanned a million and a half books
and brought them to the web they're all
they're free to read so students in the
countries that I named and students in
little villages all around the world are
able to go into that resource and read
those books these books are in a number
of different languages the ones that are
in languages that we can have been
through
optical character recognition so that
you can search inside the book and find
exactly what you're looking for it's a
very rich resource and one that we think
will become more and more important
important as we're able to do other good
technological advances like language
translation so right now a million of
these books are in Chinese but someday
you'll be able to go find the book that
you want in Chinese and have it
translated into English right in front
of your eyes students need to learn how
to use the resources in their discipline
so the accrediting agency actually now
requires that when students graduate
from the University they be nala they
have to be knowledgeable about how to
use the resources in their field whether
it's engineering or literature or
business and so part of our job in the
library is to make sure that this
happens and we do this by going into the
classroom to teach information literacy
in the junior year and at that time
students know where what they're going
to do in their profession and they want
to find out how they're going to be able
to keep on learning because unlike
people who went to school in years past
they are not going to be doing the same
job their whole lives they're going to
have to learn to do new jobs so in many
fields as quickly as less than a year
students already have to be actively
seeking seeking new knowledge in order
to keep up with the developments in
their field and that's an important job
for the libraries to make sure students
know how new information is created and
used in their discipline